I'm realizing that within my life now
because even though I'm still somewhat
passionate about making videos
I feel like there's a whole new level
and when I like for example I had a
buddy and I come here to Austin to do a
live event recently and he asked me to
come speak at it and I was like at the
gym and I'm like okay
um I'll just I'll just go because I
don't have anything else to do and it'd
be fun it sounds like fun it sounds like
I I'd be passionate about just showing
up to his live event so I just showed up
to his live event and I had the
intention of only going on stage with
him for like 40 minutes to an hour
because I had some stuff to do
afterwards I was like oh 40 minutes hour
is good I get there and I end up being
on stage for three hours we brought
people up we coach people it was
phenomenal the energy was insane
it was being recorded and I'm like oh
well now that's content I could be
putting on YouTube and it that was
assigned to me though that okay I tried
this different thing different than just
stating in front of a video like making
content I did something new I pushed my
comfort zone even though like it's not
out of my comfort zone but I could just
tell I get lit up when I'm in front of
like a crowd when I'm live it challenges
me because you have to be able to read a
room you got to be able to it's a whole
different Beast yeah exactly yeah yeah
that's so cool so I'm like I'm thinking
it kind of reminds me of like even
Abraham Hicks style stuff yeah or like
even Teal Swan I mean they're they're
people that like do live like healings
or live work essentially with people
um so I'm curious what it is that you
feel like you want to bring to the stage
like what because they correct me if I'm
wrong but I I do feel like part of the
purpose I mean you even say in the intro
like I help raise people's Consciousness
so uh expand people's Consciousness so
what is it that you want to deliver to
people from a stage that you is new like
what what what is what's in that in that
package that inspires you
yeah that's uh it's a good question
because the that's exactly what these
last like because I've taken a couple
like even just a week off of YouTube but
I've been making less content in general
that's giving me space to really go
inwards to decide like what is it that
I'm really passionate about sharing and
like helping people with and the the
kind of the underlying theme is kind of
what you're saying it's like help
helping people Elevate their level of
Consciousness raise their vibration is
kind of a new age kind of like a you
know an interesting term but in general
it's helping people Elevate their level
of awareness because I believe that
awareness is like the key to ninety
percent of transformation is awareness I
believe so the more aware you become of
the patterns in your life the more aware
you become of the belief systems that
you have the more aware you become of
the attachments of the the labels the
identity like the more aware you become
of all these things the more power you
take back to then like you know put in
life and
um at a live event what I like to do is
like help people become more aware of
these different aspects of themselves
that have been in the subconscious so
that normally happens through either
coaching people live on stage doing
group energy work another thing I'm
really passionate about that I've done
on YouTube and in different ways is I do
these uh like group meditations where we
activate our heart energies and we use
the power of group and tension to
transform our own lives and the planet
the you know like uh the ma I don't know
if you've ever heard of the Maharishi
effect it's it's similar to some of the
work Joe dispenzo is doing Dr Joe
dispenza but the Maharishi effect is
this like experiment that was done long
time ago and they re they replicate it
every so often where you get like 5 000
meditators around the world and they
focus on emoting an energy and setting
that intention
towards some specific thing so it could
be more love and peace or you know
whatever the energy is and they've
proven many times that when you get lots
of people focused on one outcome
it affects the planet in a way to where
it can decrease violent crimes on the
planet by up to like 70 percent for a
certain period of time and I'm not sure
if you've ever also the Schumann
resonance which is like the frequency of
the planet and when we do these I
remember one time may it was like May
5th like in 2020 I did this on YouTube
with 12 000 people
um that were like live at the same
moment and there were people around the
world doing this too so it wasn't just
me but we did that meditation where we
like connected into our hearts and you
know like uh connected to the group
energy which can become very powerful
and then what we did is we sent like uh
we tapped and like bring it in love and
and energy into our bodies and as we did
that there was like some people had some
very transformative experiences and I
could feel it too because I was like the
center point of like you know all those
people live and I could like feel that
energy but also the next day the
Schumann resonance which is like uh it's
like a way of gauging the frequency of
the planet it was it was all white like
it normally comes in fluxes it was all
white and it was like that's that's what
happens when people get together and
they meditate using the power of group
energy with a specific intention it can
powerfully change the planet and I think
what's happened in society is not to get
to I don't know like I don't know how
woo-woo this is but I believe that there
are people go ahead I mean I've had like
Elizabeth April on and teal and people
okay so you can do whatever the hell you
want well then I'll stretch it a little
bit I yeah I believe there are people
like I'm not a big conspiracy theory
person where I'm like in fear and all
this [ __ ] going on you know
um but in general I believe that it's a
known thing at certain levels that
there's this Collective Consciousness
that we're all connected to and I
believe that uh there are people that
maybe understand that if you keep people
in fear and in anger and in lower
vibrational emotions that their energy
is scattered right and that then it's
like they're much easier to control and
I think what's happening on the planet
right now is people are waking up
they're waking up to their own power
they're waking up to their uh like the
the ability for all of us to connect
together to create transformation on the
planet and I think that when we come
together together with group intention
like that it does the opposite of what
certain people may be doing to like keep
the collective Consciousness at a
certain level I mean when you look at
the media and the fear that's being
projected out into the world it's we're
so numb to it and so used to it but like
if you really sit down and think about
like just how much negativity is being
strung out in the media and stuff and
how there's a narrative and in a way of
thinking that really keeps people small
and keeps people very subservient to
like everything in reality
um it's so it's silly to me it's like
wow it's like we people are so bought
into that and part of the work that I
tried to do my intention at least is to
help people wake up to them being like
understanding or maybe tapping into
their spiritual component that maybe
you're an eternal spiritual being loving
a temporary Human Experience and maybe
when you come here you know you go
through crazy [ __ ] in life because and
especially early on in childhood because
I believe that that helps us to like
create pressure so that we can go
through a spiritual transformation or
through a spiritual awakening and uh
part of why I believe we came here deep
down even if we don't remember I think
as we came here to elevator level of
Consciousness to grow and to also come
together I know it sounds super [ __ ]
hippie you know but like to come
together so that we can really like
change the planet because I think that
the timeline that we may have been on
um in the past is is a timeline of like
destruction if you want to talk about
weirdness have you ever heard of Dolores
Cannon oh I love Dolores oh okay Dolores
oh Okay let's listen hours and hours and
hours and hours of Dolores she's amazing
that's awesome yeah that one thing that
really got me into this kind of content
was reading her books it was like the
con diluted Universe books I just love
like listening to some 80 year old woman
talk about the stuff she talks about so
matter-of-factly
um yeah with a grandma voice it's so
awesome
um but I feel like I've heard just about
everything that's out there on on
YouTube for her um that's how much a
listener so I probably should tap into
those books that's awesome yeah it's it
is something interesting about her just
because she does kind of have a she has
a grandma feel but she's talking about
these very esoteric things and she says
it you know she's she's had thousands
and thousands of people in deep levels
of hypnosis and it's not her saying it
it's not like I believe that you know
we're connect like ETS are real and I
believe this or that it's like these
this is what's consistently come through
thousands of people all over the world
who don't know each other they're not
like in a database like let's say this
on this hypnosis you know this deep
level of our subconscious mind let's
have this come through you know have you
ever looked into because she because one
of the things that she did was she
started teaching people how to go into
this deep deep state of hypnosis that
really nobody else was doing or at least
according to at that point in time
um to be able to go really deep into the
subconscious have you ever looked to see
if there's like a practitioner nearby or
someone that does her techniques oh yeah
my but my I have a buddy of mine that's
like uh he doesn't do sessions or
anything but he is certified like qhht
it's Quant it's called Quantum healing
hypnosis technique there it's a it's a
technique that even though she passed
away there's like a she has an
organization that trains people on how
to help people become like you know
certified in that to bring people
through past life regression or future
life regression or higher self whatever
they call it you know whatever anyone
wants to call it it's all I feel like
it's all kind of the same it's just what
name you give it exactly yeah they're
tapping into the subconscious mind and
there's information coming through one
of the interesting things I wanted to
share though about that is what they say
through some of the books the convoluted
Universe books is um which are just like
they're literally just transcripts of
her hypnosis sessions was that what
happened energetically back in the 1930s
is there were you know when the nuclear
bombs were going off and stuff what
happened is that was we were on a
timeline then of where the Earth could
possibly destroy itself because we were
experimenting with nuclear bombs and
when the nuclear bomb went off and they
were testing with it the thing is is
what she says and what people in her
hypnosis session say is that the way
Earth Works is we have free will here as
a collective to like decide what we
experience and what happened is when we
were experimenting with these nuclear
bombs it was going off and it was
Rippling out into the universe and it
was beginning to affect other reality
systems the rule is we are allowed to
affect our reality system but when we
begin affecting other reality systems
that's a No-No so what happened is uh
energetically there was like almost a
call put out to where we needed souls to
come to Earth to to Incarnate because
the rule with our reality is this Free
Will thing it's not like ETS can just
land and give us technology and we're
all fixed like we it has to come from
within the game itself and part of the
game of this reality is you come to
Earth you forget who you are there's a
veil of forgetfulness here you then go
through a process of remembering who you
are or you don't but there's an option
to like remember your spiritual nature
and who you are and then you wake up and
you go through different levels of
transformation
foreign
[Music]